And in this problem, a would equal 3. Way to go if you got that one correct.
Since a varies inversely with b, we want to make sure that we put the b quantity
in the denominator. But for c, a varies directly with it. So we want to put that
straight across in the numerator. This is perhaps the trickiest part about
setting up variation problems. And you want to make sure you get it right each
time. Remember, with inverse relationships. They'll appear in opposite
positions, whereas with direct relationships, the variables will appear directly
across from one another. So in my first case, a is 12, b is three, and c is
eight. So I plug in those values. In the second case, we don't know the value of
a, so I leave that written as a in the denominator. But I do know that b2 is
equal to six. And c2 is equal to 4. These are the values of b and c in our
second case. Now that we have this equation, we multiply these two fractions
together to get 48 divided by 12. We cross multiply to get 144 equals 48a, and
finally we divide both sides by 48 to get a is equal to 3.